you realize of course that the left
controls all of the institutions right
big tech higher education lower
education the administrative state
on and on hollywood right so if they
control all the institutions and there
is institutional racism that would be a
problem for the left
and we see this in the media here's some
institutional racism there was a story
just came out of rochester
two black teens uh burned and mentally
ill white guy to death
rochester new york the two black teens
have been charged with assault
and arson i'm not sure if they were
charged with murder
they sn snuck into the guy's home on
friday afternoon
they sprayed him with an ignitable fluid
and they set him on fire until 70
percent of his body was covered in
second-degree burns
then they left him to die uh but
thankfully
a uh a man maybe it might have been a
mailman or a worker who was checking on
the gas in the electric
uh came into the the apartment tried to
put put him out put the
the guy who was on fire put him out by
the time 9-1-1
got there though it was too late the the
victim fought for his life for four days
in a burn trauma unit and then he died a
police source
has confirmed the original reporting
which came from bob lonsberry
has confirmed that to the daily wire
you probably haven't heard of this story
if the races were reversed
this would be a national actually an
international news story
and the teens would be called white
supremacists
and they would certainly go to prison
for life
and likely receive the death penalty
uh this there would be marches in the
streets there would if
2020 is any indication there would be
riots all over the streets
stores would be broken into people would
be stealing private property in the name
of social justice
cities would be on fire but the races
are reversed here
so not only is none of that happening
but none of that's happening in large
part well no
none of it would happen anyway but one
of the reasons none of it's happening is
because the media just won't cover it
are these kids being charged with a hate
crime i don't know what is a hate crime
hate crime
sort of a silly phrase it's a silly idea
the idea that you know certain crimes
are hate crimes so presumably other
crimes are love crimes
i don't i don't know about that student
crimes are lukewarm crimes maybe
but the idea that you should receive a
harsher sentence because of your
motivations
that somehow the jury will be able to
discern
with specificity all of your motivations
and then be able to meet out at just
punishment based on that
you're not hearing about any of that
it's going to be swept
under the rug was it racist i don't know
maybe certainly psychopathic
why these two teenagers are going to be
permitted into society ever again is
beyond me
but that's the society that we live in
if you enjoyed that video be sure to hit
the subscribe button so
everyone waiting through the wasteland
of youtube knows that we've got
the absolute top content out there